- Greetings everyone.
I'm really excited to welcome
professor Kathleen Cruz
Gutierrez here today,
especially because her
work resonates with so many
of the exciting conversations
that are going on at Yale
and elsewhere at the intersection of
environmental humanities,
Southeast Asian studies, history.
And of course in my own
field of anthropology
where everyone is talking
about the entanglements
of plants and humans
as well as science and technology studies,
which Dr. Gutierrez is deeply involved in.
She's working at the forefront
of all of these fields
and using the critical
study of the history
of botanical science to
rethink a range of assumptions
about Philippines history, ideas of region
in Southeast Asia, not
to mention just region
but how Southeast Asian has
themselves imagine the idea
of Southeast Asia itself
and the role of science
in imperial and nationalist formations.
I think there's a lot
of conversations to have
between faculty at UC Santa Cruz
where she has recently taken up a position
as assistant professor and
all of us here at Yale.
And I hope this conversation today
will be just the first of many to come.
I wanna say a little bit
about her recent dissertation
in my course, on the politics
of culture in Southeast Asia
we read and discussed this
brilliant piece of work
The Region of Imperial Strategy.
And we had a vibrant discussion
and all of us in the class
found it to be extremely multilayered.
And in the course I asked
students to write book reviews
of the works we read
and I thought it would
be appropriate to quote
from one such review written
by Orven Mallari, who is here.
You could see Orven there
I didn't know Orven would be here
but a brilliant undergraduate
student who actually
is majoring in a STEM field
but interested in the Philippines
and Southeast Asian studies.
So I'm just gonna read one paragraph
I hope you don't mind Orven
I've just snatched a paragraph
from your brilliant review.
Orven writes, "In the
region of Imperial strategy
Kathleen Gutierrez asks us
to move the kaleidoscope
through which we have
been viewing the history
of the Philippines if only slightly
in a way that brings the
unexpectedly rich story of botany
into the political history of the nation.
In doing so we pry open an
unseen network of individuals
and institutions ripe
with new stories to tell.
Seeing Filipino history bound
through Prescott's paradigm
the seemingly unconscious
division of a pre 1898
and post 1898 Philippines,
Gutierrez seeks to uproot
this tyranny of historiography
to portray the role
of scientific collaboration
and fostering the makings
of an inter Imperial hegemony of thought.
For Gutierrez the Philippines
is not merely a peripheral
figure in the arena
of European imperialism's
decline at the start
of the 20th century,
but a central hub of it.
The seeds of post-imperial
and post-colonial logics
were not planted in
the halls of their site
or the international botanical Congress
but within the letters sent
from the gardens of Manila."
I think it's such a beautiful evocation
of this rich tapestry of
science and technology studies,
Southeast Asian studies that we encounter
in professor Gutierrez's dissertation.
And so I just wanna use that as a window
to open us into today's conversation.
Today's discussion will be
sort of a talk show format
and so I wanna build
from Orven's introduction
to the dissertation there
and ask professor Gutierrez
to tell us a little bit more
about this dissertation,
The Region of Imperial Strategy.
You describe a series of
Spanish era and an American era
botanical texts and then you
use these to make an argument
about the emergence of a
kind of botanical science
that transforms Philippine history.
So I wondered if you could
just tell us a little bit
about some of these texts
and some of the actors that
you so brilliantly discuss
in the dissertation and
how you mobilize those
to get us to think of new ways
about the Philippines, Southeast
Asia, and other things.
- Sure, thank you so much.
And thanks for the introduction
Orven that was amazing
(laughs) very generous of you
and your description of it
and I think you really
hit the nail on the head.
I mean, so much of the
Genesis of the dissertation
came from this problem
what's happening around 1898?
Why is science especially
projected in this way
in which we have sort of the
Spanish Imperial backwater
and then we have the us progressive period
in Philippine history.
And I wanted to just investigate
it a little bit more,
see what was going on, see
what was actually salient
and then find where there
was something divergent
and it came down to botany.
And so if you sort of muddy 1898
as the strict division and
Philippine colonial history
you actually see quite a bit of similarity
across the two botany projects
under the Spanish and the US.
And so by looking at certain texts
I was able to find that
one of those things
that muddies 1898 is this preoccupation
with the region, this
idea of the Philippines
being a part of a floristic region.
And so there were Spanish botanists
who were invested in that,
and there were US botanists
invested in this as well.
And so by way of texts,
one the texts I look at
during the Spanish era
is this 1883 publication
by Sebastian Beadle.
Who's this Catalan botanist
perhaps the most famous
secular Spanish botanist
in the late 19th century
in the Philippians.
It's illustrated with Regina Garcia
who's a local illustrator, a
Filipino local illustrator.
And they're really interested
in putting the Philippines flora
in conversation with other
flora from Island Southeast Asia
would become Island Southeast Asia.
The same is happening in the US period
particularly with the
work of Elmer di Merrill
who's perhaps the most
well-known US colonial botanist
that we have in Philippine history.
And he's working on regional flora slowly
while he's in the Philippines.
He's looking at Indochina, he's looking at
the Indian sub-continent,
he's looking at Ambun
in the Dutchy Cindys, and
he's putting the Philippines
in conversation with
regional flora as well.
And so for me, I'm really
curious in the dissertation about
what exactly is connecting
this intellectual trend.
And I argue that in part
it's happening as a result of
kind of how botany is internationalizing
and becoming sort of this
Neo-Imperial formation
of international collaboration.
And one of those strategies
is through region building
and flora becomes a really
great determining platform
for this.
In Ireland, Southeast Asia but
what we would really again.
consider the broader region.
You asked about people, Erik
and so I divide the dissertation
through these stories
of three individuals.
Regina Garcia who I
mentioned is this illustrator
who also is kind of known as a botanist
who learns it on the job
even though he doesn't
have formal training.
Sebastian Vidal, the
secular Spanish botanist,
who even though his is really
famous in the Philippines
at the end of the 19th century,
his career gets eclipsed
in the historiography in many ways
I think because there's this
focus on US Imperial science
that clouds what's happening
during Spanish period.
And then my third main
actor is Mary Strong Clemons
who is a US plant collector.
She collects all throughout
what would become Southeast Asia.
And so I follow her career a little bit
through the Philippians.
And by looking at her
career I'm able to open up
conversations about local
collectors in the Philippines
who were also contributing
to botany at the time.
And what I love about these people is that
their careers overlap.
Some of them collaborate with one another,
some of them mention each
other in their correspondence,
and they really help
again, sort of muddy 1898.
I think when you follow
actors who are just kind of
pushing aside periodization
for a moment in our narratives
and allowing us to see what
other dynamic configurations
are happening intellectually at the time.
- [Erik] Thank you, Kathleen.
I have this book actually that
because when I read your dissertation,
I looked in the Yale library.
This is the one by Vidal
(speaks in foreign language).
And it's the one and I'm
also sharing with the group
the names of those people,
because I have it in my notes
from reading your dissertation
so people can have those names.
But if I open this, I'm just curious
if I open this and show it to the group.
I don't know if people can see
can people see this when I share this?
Can you just say what it's
like to encounter this
in the archive and how
opening a book like this
reveals something about
Philippine history.
I was trying to communicate this
with the students in my class
but I hadn't yet got the
book from the library
it took a couple of days to get it.
And I'm just curious like
there's these archival materials, right?
That are in all these
libraries around the world
and hidden in them as these
kind of hidden stories.
I wonder if you could
unpack that a little bit-
- Sure.
- [Erik] In the encounter
with one of the plates
because there's something
in your dissertation as well
the way in which you
attend to the drawings.
And there's like a kind
of almost an archive
inscribed into the
drawings themselves, right?
- Yeah.
- [Erik] I wonder if you could
expound on that a little bit.
- Definitely, yeah.
Thank you so much for
bringing the text out.
And you know, I have to admit
that part of my investigation
began with Vidal, he sort of
left behind the best archive
from this period in Philippine history
and it's all in Madrid.
But what I was starting to
discover as I was looking through
Vidal's archive was this
sort of peripheral character
who would just emerge this Riheno Garcia,
who he collected with, who took
him around the Philippines,
somehow his resume, right?
Well, we would have the
resume in Spanish service
appears in Madrid which is really unlikely
for a Philippine born in Filipino.
And so I kind of started
following the breadcrumbs
through that and Garcia's
name appears, right?
In this particular text
as the lead illustrator.
And it was only through
following Garcia that I realized
that there was this
larger story to be told
about this one locally born
individual who starts off
as an artist who gets hired
at the botanical garden
of Manila in part because
he needs to help raise
his younger siblings.
Put's society's fine arts degree
and kind of goes in
and works in the garden
and becomes really the lead illustrator
for the Spanish colonial project
I mean the last decades
of the 19th century.
And so process wise, you
know, I'm looking at this text
for much more significance
than I think that I
had originally gone in.
And I was telling Erik
this, that I would spend
maybe like 30 minutes to an hour
just looking at a plate,
figuring what was so different
about it and unique at the time.
And only after maybe consulting
with another art historian
was I realizing that Garcia was doing
something really artistically different
with botanical plates
compared to his contemporaries
who were synopsis, the synopsis genre
in other locations, other countries
and certainly other colonial terrain.
He's doing things that's
allowing him to deploy
his sort of fine arts acumen.
So if you look at the
plate that Erik showed,
plants are overlapping, they're kind of
there's a 3D element to it and vibe
a kind of a lushness with
the page that's coming out.
So very different from a linear
organization of plant life
or even insect life that you're seeing
in contemporary publications.
And this kind of lack of linearity,
this ability to show plant life
almost as a kind of lushness
of the archipelago.
I think it's speaking to a
moment again where these texts
or these images are communicating
a different kind of Philippine
flora that's more inviting.
And I think it's also reflective
of Garcia's own knowledge
of what's happening in the environment.
Yeah and thank you so much Orven
for showing that image as well
thankfully in the archive,
I was able to find Garcia's process picks
from sketch to the rendered
painting of a similar plant
to the actual image that
shows up in the synopsis.
And you can just see how
complex these images are
Russell Monarrez, was a
really well-known historian
of the Philippines says that
the 1880s is known as this time
in Philippine history
when we see the most
important publications
to Philippine nationalism come out
including the Noleen by Jose Resal.
I actually think the synopsis
is one of those texts
and it's doing this in really
incredible illustrated ways
that we can continue to
read as its own archive.
- [Erik] Thanks for that explanation.
There's two discussions
in your dissertation
that I think it could be useful to share
with this group here
who hasn't had the
opportunity to read it yet,
most people probably.
You talk a little bit
about this kind of like
the botany of the friars you might say,
and how it's discredited in
the global scientific community
that's emerging around
the turn of the century,
if I'm not mistaken.
And it'd be useful if you
could explain some of that
and how you also are
rethinking that a little bit.
And then also you described
this emergent concept
of I'm not sure how it's pronounced
I read it as a Malesia
but it may be just pronounced Malaysia
it's M-A-L-E-S-I-A
as what I think you call
it a floristic region.
And so I'd love to hear a little
bit about those two things
and then I'll have another question
about the floristic region, but I see
that we already have
questions from the group.
So I have a couple more questions
and then we'll turn to
questions from the group.
- Yeah yeah thank you.
And I see you Kirby.
Hi (laughs) (mumbles).
To get onto the question about friar
and kind of friar intellectual
botanical knowledge, right?
And botanical production, I
think in Philippine history,
one of the best study friars
who is up to kind of natural
at this work is Francisco Manuel Blanco.
We studied his Florida Filipinos
which was written and published in 1837
sort of up and down as
one of the first texts
of Philippine botany.
And this is being done
both in the social sciences
and in sciences as well
I mean, we're still really
investigating his work.
And I think it's an
important text, no doubt
but what I find really
fascinating in the archives
is at least by the 19th century
the Spanish state is really
trying to separate itself
from the work of the Spanish friars
and the work that's being done
by secular officials in the Spanish state.
I kind of call this more of
like a scientific state craft
if you will.
Other scholars have looked
at how late Spanish empire
starts to double down and really
show its intellectual chops
to sort of the new Imperial world
this is happening as well in
the Philippines with botany.
And so at some point there
were some great letters
in Madrid covering this
different metropolitan
centers are interested
in the botany that's going
on in the Philippines.
They're asking for texts that are coming
and being produced on the Philippines.
And some of them ask for
Lancos Florida Filipinas
the Spanish state actually
comes in and says,
"Yeah, it's good."
But that was an Augustinian publication
and now look at the
synopsis, check this out.
I mean, this is my
hilarious summarizing of it
but I think that's a really
important moment, right?
This distinction that's starting to happen
between sort of friar
science and the science
in the secular state.
And what it's supposed to be doing
for positioning the Spanish empire
in a very different way in botany
than it had been in the first
1/2 of the 19th century.
There's a much more money
going into botany at the end
of the 19th century than we've
really seen in other parts
of the 19th century.
When it comes to Malaysia or Malesia
depending on how you pronounce it.
I think it's a really important
kind of floristic region
to take note of, because what we're seeing
at least in this time period
around the turn of the century
is that botanists are
creating a region of their own
that they believe is
prescribed by plant life.
Really the movement of
particular plant genera
across the different domains.
What they're acknowledging
is that this plant genera is
really a vast (mumbles) terrains
so it's no longer just
about Philippine flora
versus Duchies, in these flora versus that
in British Malaya you're
seeing what the flora is
across these domains.
And so Malaysia as a region
starts to gain a lot of credence
and salience among these botanists.
Why do I find this
interesting well, I'm a child
of area studies I've been
in Southeast Asian studies
until I was 18 I love the field
And for all of us who were trained
in Southeast Asian studies
we know that the apogee is
really around world war II.
(person clears throat)
To film and gain social
scientific prominence
as a result of world war II
and eventually cold war politicking.
I'd like to push that a
little bit further back
and if you look at the domain of science,
specifically botany region
making was happening
well before world war II.
And again, I think a
lot of these botanists
are sort of seeing themselves
as standing outside of
politics and politicking.
But when you look at again,
the sort of interim period
configuration that's
happening at the time,
they're very much part of it
but they're using sort of
botany as this explanation
for why and sort of reach
and making will make sense.
And so Malaysia as a place,
really takes part in that
and it's still considered
a floristic sub-region
of the Indo-Malayan biogeographic zone.
So there are presently
botanists and scientists
within Southeast Asia who are contributing
to the flora Malaysiana catalog,
and really still seeing
it as a concrete place
where we can map forum.
- [Erik] Thanks Kat this
is really fascinating
and someday I'd love to ask
you much deeper questions
about Malaysia, but I wanted
to turn to another part
of your dissertation for sake of time.
Let's say somebody comes
to you and they say
botany nationalism, I
don't see the connection
can you explain it?
You have a chapter in your dissertation
where you're talking about
the sampaguita flower
and I think it would be useful
maybe to tell us a little bit
about what you're doing in that chapter.
And remember, most people
haven't read the dissertation
so if you could describe
what you're doing there
and what is the sampaguita flower
and how does this offer a kind
of window into the confluence
of botany, nationalism, floristic regions,
all of these kinds of things
that you're dealing with?
- Sure, sure.
Yeah and then for those
of you who have read
the dissertation overhauling
the chapter presently (laughs)
so it's changing a little bit
but thanks for bringing that up, Erik.
So the sampaguita, for those
of you who might not know
it's the national flower
of the Philippines
it's kind of the darling flower.
It has a lot of popular significance
in the Philippines and you sort of see it
pedaled on the streets of Manila.
It comes up in a lot of
cultural production presently
both in diaspora and in
the Philippines itself.
So I'm really curious in that chapter
about really kind of taking
that sampaguita to task
and just questioning for a moment
that it's always been in
the Philippine imaginary
really trying to locate when it emerges
and gains kind of that power,
that political valence.
And I locate that in the late 19th century
where I start to see I'm able to identify
at the intersection of
intellectual thought in Manila,
scientific production and
botany and cultural production,
how the sampaguita becomes this
emblem for the protonation.
And so I argue kind of in
the revision of the chapter
that it does so because of it's gendered
and gender inequalities that get mapped on
to the nation itself or the nation form.
The sampaguita at the time
really becomes the stand-in
for ideal femininity.
She is light-skinned, she's
fragrant, she's in bloom,
she's in her prime, she's reproductive.
Historian. Raquel Rayez
has looked at sort of this
before and how gender plays
a really important role
in how the mother country of
the Philippians gets developed
specifically in illustrado
or enlightened intellectual thinking
at the end of the 19th century.
What I think you can add
to that though is botany
and this flower and I actually would argue
that ideal femininity comes by way
of like looking at a flower as well.
And so there's sort of
this co-constitution
of ideal femininity and
the idea of the flower
and how this gets repurposed
for creating the archipelago
or archipelagic space.
Manila intellectuals at the
time are starting to suggest
that this flower is ubiquitous,
it's everywhere in the archipelago.
You don't even have to describe it
because you just have
to show it to someone
and they'll be able to name it
and they write on it like this
and they're distinguishing it from like
the Peninsular Jasmine they're saying that
it's something very specific
it only grows in the Philippines.
Botany publications are you
know, producing information
on the plant.
But if you actually look at the literature
many of the observations
around the sampaguita
are quite localized.
They're in Manila, they're
in parts of the Visayas
in the central region.
And yet it's starting
to come into dominance
as sort of this popular emblem.
And so I think in the late 19th century
that's when it's really
starting to take hold
when nationalists are seeing this
as a unique subject or object
to start mapping, right?
And then eventually, the
sampaguita gets declared
the national flower in 1934
and we've had it since.
And so I think having
this history is important
especially when we
invest, I think in sort of
nationalist projects that take
on plant life as emblematic
of the nation.
And I think there's
always a history to this
and never really just an
acceptance of it always been,
you know, for me.
- [Erik] Thank you.
This is so fascinating this discussion
and going through the way
in which even a plant itself
can become a new archive
into our understandings
of nationalism and region.
I have a lot of questions,
but I know that Kirby
had a question up for a couple of times
and I wanna make sure
this is a multiple voices
come into our conversation.
So I'll hold back on my
questions and see where we go
and then if we run out of questions,
I'll bring some back in.
But Kirby please ask your question
and then after that I see
someone named Cresa Pugh
also has her hand up
so we'll start with Kirby
and after that, we'll turn to Cresa
and then anyone else put your hand up
and I'll keep track of the names.
- [Kirby] Hi, good evening from Manila.
So good morning, early
morning now in Manila.
So (speaks in foreign
language) I have two questions.
Okay, first you did an
extensive study or analysis
of Sebastian Vidali Solar's work.
How unique is his work
compared to an earlier botanist
who did the same botanical research
in Manila in the late 18th century?
Huondi Quelear, so how
unique is Vidal's work
compared to Quelear
and second you mentioned,
I forgot his name
the name of the Filipino partner,
or a coworker of Vidali Solar.
What do you think that in the 19th century
there was this tradition of
scientific apprenticeship
or there's the clear tandem
among state scientists
or colonial scientists at that time?
So even the (murmurs)
had some native, okay
apprentice who did the
nitty gritty of work.
Meaning they did the fieldwork,
they were sent to the secondary stations
to do the field work in the same with
for example, the civil
and mining engineers
who did geological and mining surveys
for example, in the zone.
So the likes of (murmurs) had
the service of photographer
in Riqe Delmonte, although Riqe Delmonte
is a Philippine (murmurs) I suppose.
So how would you assess the idea
of scientific apprenticeship
during that particular
period in the 19th century?
So thank you.
- Thanks Kurbs, hi (laughs).
You know, I think these are
great very Philippine history,
specific questions so
I'm happy to answer them
and I'll try to be as general as possible
to make them pretty accessible.
On the question on the
Vidal and his difference
with Quelear or Quoyar.
So Quoyar is an interesting figure
and he sort of the
naturalists par excellence
and long history of
botany in the Philippians.
I think Vidal is a bit different
from him in the sense that
Vidal is really deployed
to the Philippines
towards a lot more institutional building.
Queyar's visit to the
Philippines, his study of flora
in many ways is also kind
of a commercial expedition,
he doesn't quite get to the point
of institution building, right?
As Vidal does for various circumstances
and Vidal is courted by
the Spanish statement
I think a different way
than Queyar is, right?
If you especially think
of the late 18th century
where the Spanish state was in terms of
developing scientific institutions
this was really kind of the realm
of the Royal society still,
but by the late 19th century
you see Vidal not only deployed
to the archipelago himself
he's coming with a team of foresters
of botany trained men from the peninsula.
His brother is in the Philippines too,
his uncle is in the Philippines
and they're all really taking up botany
in a different way I think.
That light leads into your
next question about training
I wouldn't call it
apprenticeship so much, actually.
And I can tell you why,
in the case of Garcia
but training is happening specifically
at the botanical garden of
Manila, school of agriculture.
They actually instituted
this pension out a program
to bring in students from
across the archipelago,
young men to study in botany and forestry
to then be deployed back
across the archipelago.
What is unique about that is
we actually credit the pension
out a program to something
of the United States, right?
The bringing of young
people from the Philippines
to the United States to train,
to send them back to the Philippines
to take up government
posts or teaching posts.
This is happening in the
Philippines under a span
it's just happening in a
sort of within the colony.
And so that training is happening,
more men from the peninsula
are also coming in
and they're leaving to
different parts of the islands.
The reason why I wouldn't use
apprenticeship so much though
is because in the case of Garcia.
Oh gosh I actually don't
even think of him as so much
as an apprentice, as I
think of him in many ways
as someone who is able to
stay institutionally in place
as a person who was local,
who had elite standing
but also had enough
connections to kind of stay
within the botany institutions
and outlast his Spanish contemporaries.
Garcia is an interesting
character because he's really
the longest standing person working
for Spanish secular
botany me through the end
of the 19th century.
I don't really think of
that as apprenticeship
and when you see him come
in to the botanical garden
of Manila, he's not trained.
And actually Spanish
records make many critiques
of him or his lack of training.
And there's not a lot of effort,
I think to necessarily put him in training
or even send him back to the peninsula
this is something he's
learning on the job.
And then I would say in
his relationship with Vidal
when Vidal finally arrives
in the archipelago,
I consider them equals
actually I consider that
Vidal's Corpus really only takes shape,
really only gets off the ground
because of what Garcia is doing.
Both illustrating his
texts, but also helping him
go around the archipelago
and collecting with him
along the way.
Vidal dies an untimely
death in the 19th century
and it's actually Garcia who
is responsible for collecting
and organizing his plant
life that's in the barium.
Because he was the most familiar
with what those collecting
expeditions have been.
And so I'd love to talk to
you a little bit more about,
what's happening at the Jesuit observatory
and even sort of the use
of the term apprenticeship
'cause I think there's
something maybe different
and maybe similar happening
in botany, but yeah
there may be something a
little bit more divergent.
Thanks Kirby.
- [Erik] Thanks Kirby for
such a provocative question
and Kat for such a wonderful answer.
Next, we have a question from Cresa Pugh
and Cresa please if I've
mispronounced your name,
feel free to correct me.
- Yeah, it's Cresa
thank you so much.
And thank you, Kathleen
for this really fascinating presentation.
I have a question which is maybe
beyond the scope of your dissertation.
So I apologize in advance
of it is, but I'm wondering
about the role of kind
of how decoloniality
or specifically anti-coloniality
appear in your work.
I'm particularly curious about,
to what extent have there
been attempts to kind of
unravel these Imperial
institutions and that you speak on?
Have there been attempts
to make indigenous claims
to the botanical specimens
that you referenced?
I remember a couple of years ago
when I was in the
Singapore botanical gardens
and there were these
pretty significant efforts
to rename a lot of the specimens
from their botanical Latin
names to their indigenous names
and even replanting native
trees to replace plants
that had been imported from the colonies.
And I really saw that as
a kind of decolonial move
and so I'm wondering how,
you know, decoloniality
and anti-coloniality even
show up on your work.
- Yeah, thanks so much
Cresa for that question.
And it's really coming up much more
in how I'm revising
towards the manuscript.
I think these questions are important
because as compelling as sort of this
Imperial internationalist narrative is
I'm really curious about
what's still happening locally?
What's being obscured
perhaps by the name botany
but is never actually destroyed by it.
And so my focus on the dissertation
is really looking at that
vibrancy of botanical vernaculars
and by vernaculars I
don't only mean sort of
linguistically how plants were called
outside of Latin binomial nomenclature
but vernacular knowledge of plants.
That even historians perhaps
aren't really looking at
or haven't looked at yet completely.
And so in a project like
mine, that's looking at
the turn of the century,
I'm looking at for instance,
weaving and textile implements.
Particularly because female weavers
as they were mostly
female during this time
really don't kind of emerge
in a typical study of botany
in the Philippines
and yet their practices were
almost entirely plant-based.
I mean these were plant based technologies
where they were relying
on and not just dyes,
but also loon technologies as well.
And so how do then read
these materials for instance
as vernacular knowledge
plants that are still thriving
if not expanding during this period
but again are somewhat obscured by only
an Imperial botany narrative at the time.
I think the sampaguita work
also is important in this
especially if we're thinking
about anti-colonial politics
that are developing or at least politics
of self-determination that
emerged during this period.
And I'm also looking in
terms of nomenclature
'cause that's what she also brought up
at how plant varietals,
varietals of rice in particular.
And I've mentioned
this, I think when Megan
was in a different talk
about how rice varietals
are abandoned in the Philippines
and how as we currently know
it sort of the Latin name
Oryza Sativa, right?
For rice existed in the Philippines
botanists were using that
and yet botanists didn't know what to do
with the dozens of rice
varietals that had been present,
that had local names.
And so for me, I'm really
curious about the epistemologies
of plants ordering that
were very divergent from
Leneyan botany, instead of
focusing on for instance
morphological characteristics
that define a relationship.
How are people in the colony
at the time using things
like touch, taste, feel
a rice in the mouth after
or before cooking, right?
The stage of a rice plant's growth,
where it is in it;s cycle,
how do all of those names
actually reveal an incompleteness
in Leneyan botany, and
it's in that incompleteness
of Leneyan botany that I
think we find a way cooler
local history to tell
through plant knowledge.
So thanks Cresa.
- Such fascinating discussions,
Denise Margaret Mathias
I believe you have a question?
- Yes so good afternoon,
everyone or good evening
from where I am.
I'm from the Institute for
Social Ecological Research
in Bonn, Germany.
So Kat, I was just wondering
about when you were doing
your archival work whether
there was also a list
of introduced species.
So I'm quite interested, like to map out
when did this introduced species such as
(speaks in foreign language)
come to the Philippines
and yeah if you've seen that.
Yeah, thank you.
- Yeah you know, I have
to credit some of the work
of historical botanists in the Philippians
that are doing this right
now that are really tracking
the introduction of particular species.
Domingo Medulin in particular,
perhaps the most prolific
historical botanist
has been doing this from
the early Spanish Imperial
colonial period, by the late
19th century, we do see this
in ledgers of exchange
between the botanical garden
in Manila and other botanical gardens
that are present for
instance in Hong Kong,
that are in Singapore and
in the Dutch East Indies.
It's hard to know though
I mean, I think I haven't
done enough critical work
to look at the introduction
of particular species
but we do know at the
very least at this time
that there is a much more a
acclimatization work in place
to try to raise other tropical species
on the garden grounds.
And so those ledgers there in Madrid,
Denise if you're ever interested in them
I can even try to dig some
up for you to look through
that might be able to start
placing some of these plants.
But I would say the much earlier kind of
introduction of plants
you'd have to look maybe at the work
of Domingo Medulin really,
really excellent stuff
but we can definitely talk offline.
- Great, thank you.
Michael Van coming in from the
West coast as well I believe.
it's good to see you again.
(talking over each other)
- [Michael] Yes I am (laughs).
Thank you so much for this great
I'm committed to stand here
(murmurs) that I have
not read the dissertation
and I'm also gonna commit the sin
of asking a question
that like is something
that I'm obsessed with in my own research
but is there a discourse
on invasive species?
Yeah that resonates with nationalism.
And is there also as a sub-colonially
any understanding of Magellan exchange
colonialism facilitating not plants
that are being acclimatized
but plants that are invading
and going out of control.
- Oh yeah.
Great, thank you so much Michael.
And hi, you know, that doesn't appear
I can't say that in the
texts that I've worked with
from that time period
both that are being produced
by botanists, but then also
among intellectuals who
are writing on plant life
they're not really commenting on invasion.
But they're either using that language
of plants that are coming
in and certainly not
sort of tying back all the way to Magellan
is not what I necessarily found.
Although I will say that
that kind of discourse
has come up in a more contemporary sense.
I mean, actually tying back
to the sampaguita, right?
I mean, the sampaguita
itself is not necessarily
a native of the Philippines.
It's not endemic to the Philippines rather
it's actually endemic to South Asia.
And so even in the question of nativeness
of this plant, right?
That sort of gets thrown into the air
in particular with debates
about if another plant
should actually be positioned
as the national plant of the Philippines.
And this has happened with
an orchid from Mindanal
but this talk about
invasion versus nativeness,
as you know Michael can become
really dangerous territory
especially as how plants can
be positioned in rhetoric
that has been easily alleged
against people, right?
And so I think even when
I sort of think about
more contemporary debates
and how I place that
into turn of the century
problems of invasion
although I will look out for
it now more in my archive
I'm trying to be a little
bit more careful too
about how my own work might be positioned
for kind of nativist rhetoric
versus an invasive rhetoric
that might actually be undoing
some of my own politics
I think doing this work altogether.
Also happy to talk about
this more if I find
some information for you, Michael thanks.
And I also wanna hear
about why you're interested
in invasion too.
- [Michael] Oh well rats.
- Oh, rats yeah, exactly.
Michael has a great.
(talking over each other)
Yeah, yeah, yeah absolutely
thank you for that.
- Thanks I believe the next
question is from Al Lim
and then after that will be Max Finley.
- Hi, thank you so much for
this I'm in Erik's class
so I had a chance to read
this amazing dissertation
and specifically I'm
thinking about measurement.
I'm wondering what is
specific about the techniques
of measurement that
locals or botanists use
and specifically thinking
about agential realism
that's in the chapter three,
the variety and notion
of kind of interaction and the phenomenon
and collapsing subject
object in that sense.
So I'm just thinking
about how that sampaguita
might be similar or
different to for example,
the (mumbles) family and
the plates that we see
in chapter two.
So yeah, will love to hear about that.
- Measurement huh?
Standards of measurement.
That's a great question, right.
And in Lunean botany there seems to be
what becomes kind of a vocabulary
a shared vocabulary of measurement, right?
I mean, these texts are sharing
ways of describing plants
by size for instance,
and they're able to maybe
describe them through Latin
and this is something that's
getting shared across empires.
And so this becomes a standard
way of understanding how
we describe plants, right?
There's this shared vocabulary,
a shared style of measurement.
What I think is really cool though
and I think what you're bringing up around
sort of the subject objects
and the possibilities
for agential realism is how
that measurement of a plant
or even the scale of a plant can change
depending on the discourse.
And so if you look back to chapter three,
you think back to the sampaguita
and you think about measurement
and growing space, right?
And how that growing
space actually enlarges
depending on sort of the imagination.
And then, I say imagination
but I mean sort of how
intellectuals at the time
are both grounding their imagination
in scientific texts but also allowing
for a national imagination
to really enlarge the growing
expense of the sampaguita.
And then we have sort of measurement
turned on its head, right?
We actually are inverting
sort of the land,
the norms of measurement
and plant description
and allowing it to become
sort of allowing the plant
to become much more encompassing
of the white archipelago.
And that's a really exciting part, right?
How does the sampaguita itself
sort of push these Lunean norms?
So really thank you for bringing that up
it's something that I probably
should incorporate more
on the revision.
Thanks Al.
- Max Finley, I think you have a question?
- Yes thank you.
And thank you very much
Professor Gutierrez,
Kat for that presentation.
I really want to read
your dissertation now
I even wanna read the book even more.
So I guess the first question is
when is the book going to come out?
And second question is
and forgive me if I go on
a little bit with this
one, I'm very curious
I think following up on
questions two and four,
Cresa and Michael.
From a different perspective though
about this internationalizing botany
and this creation of floral zones.
And I'm very curious in particular
how much of the Philippines
who are the botanists
in both periods who were
matching these zones
are creating these zones
how much of the Philippines
were they accessing?
Is there a geographic bias
in the kind of flowers
they're putting forward?
For example, just because I
happen to have it on my desk
I was thinking about German
travels in the cordillera
the translations by William Henry Scott.
And he has a few people there,
but are they part contributing
to this international dialogue at all?
Or for that matter are
certain geographies such as
they forgot the Cordillera
or Mindanao being excluded
and to borrow a Michael's
language being turned
almost into invasive species within it
even though they are very much
endemic or very much part?
Are parts of the Philippines
being included versus excluded?
I guess that's the broad question.
- That's great, yeah thanks Max.
Fun facts for everyone I
met Max in the UST archives
the University of Santo
Thomas (laughs) archives
back in 2018.
So it's just great to see you here again
it's been a long time.
When's the book coming out?
I have my history
colleagues, some of them here
in the call, give me some time (laughs)
it's gonna get there hashtag
COVID but it will be there
and keep an eye out for it.
In terms of internationalizing botany
that I can talk about
a little bit more about
and geographic bias.
I actually think geographic
bias is happening
on different scales in the dissertation
and in how we look at this history, right?
Even if botany is
internationalizing at the time
the biggest movers and shakers of botany
are all sort of Imperial
metropolitan centers.
And so the notion of the
international is really
only kind of geographically
limited to Europe at the time.
And this sort of extends to the
United States at some point,
but it's pretty limited.
I think when we're thinking
about Philippine flora as well
the geographic biases is mostly in Duzon
and certainly Manila.
These are very well studied
locations for botany
up until sort of the early 20th century.
There are other investigations
that are happening
I mean, there's this extension
penetration of Mindenal.
It starts around the
mid 19th century as well
and it's flora is getting
sort of considered
in this colonial catalog that's building.
But I would even argue
that again, much of this
colonial catalog is
really sort of situated
in the colonial capital, radiates outward,
and then only kind of decades later
is it incorporating other zones.
And so you asked, about
Cordilleran peoples
or peoples in Mindanao, and
whether plant life there
is sort of getting considered, right?
Or if it's being considered invasive
or if there's a particular rhetoric.
I actually think during this
late Spanish colonial period
not enough is really known
but what is known is
the commercial potential
of these locations,
particularly the timber
that's coming out of Mindanao.
And that makes it become a much more
lucrative place for investigation.
But I would say in terms of
taxonomic botany, absolutely
there is still kind of
this geographic bias
up through kind of the earliest decades
of the US colonial period.
And then that has again,
lead into questions about
well what are we considering
as part of regional botany
as it's developing at the time?
What's being constituted as
participating in this creation
of the regional zone
and how are those
limitations being expressed?
And that guys, it ties
back into Al's question,
where does measurement then
become a little bit more elastic?
Geographical space
become much more elastic
to meet these intellectual ends.
- Thanks, next question is from Orven.
- Hello, hello doctor.
So I was really inspired
by Cresa's point earlier
as was a lot of people in
the rest of the comments.
And I think a lot of my
questions have actually
been answered, but I'm thinking like
just in terms of the dissertation itself
right like sort of
narrative that you build
with the three sort of like protagonists
is I think really really interesting way
to kind of break through that kind of like
the kind of blinders
that we have called 1898
and just kind of create
a more nuanced take
on that period in Philippine history.
But throughout, I was kind of wondering
like of the presence of
kind of India and right
like India or like native, as you say
like kind of actors and players.
I mean obviously like
regional Garcia is like
it's kind of like a peninsula
not a peninsula, the opposite of that.
Shoot, what is that?
Huh?
(talking over each other)
- Insula yeah.
- Yeah it looks like an insula
but that's still like within as he said,
like the colonial
Metropole and even through
like the later chapters
within the building
like the construction of the sampaguita as
this national symbol is a very illustrator
sort of move, right?
And these kinds of like
anti-colonial or decolonial projects
it's kind of like a common theme
throughout Southeast Asian studies
has a really uncomfortable
Alliance with nationalism.
And so kind of wondering like
is this dissertation just
like the lack of India voices
in this dissertation sort of just makes it
kind of like a victim
of the archive of sort
Because obviously a lot of
these letters are written
to and from colonial centers
to Spain and stuff like that.
And secondly, looking
forward into the conclusion
of your book, I was reading
some really interesting
kind of implications of this
sort of international botany
and sort of like nationalistic
or imperialistic science
however you wanna call it.
For example (laughs) I think
you cited one of your works
called Imelda Marcos Toad Lily.
I think that's just the
greatest title I've seen
in work of academia, but
I was wondering like right
like what can we look
forward to in the future
in terms of or at least
future as in like beyond 1945
in terms of what neural botany
played in the Philippines?
- Yeah oh, what a cool question.
Thanks Orven.
And I love that point about
sort of Southeast Asian studies,
give us kind of uncomfortable
Alliance with nationalism.
It's what we studied, you know?
I mean like tell me a Southeast Asianist
who hasn't asked this question (laughs)
or like written about
it somewhere for a class
or at some point in their
own personal body of work.
You're right, you're absolutely right.
I mean, these characters, these people
had archives to leave.
And even then though, I mean
we have to kind of go back
to Garcia his was much much
slimmer than Mary Clemmons
or Sebastian Vidal.
I mean, you have this visual archive
that I think is the most
robust, but even then
I mean, in that's slim,
lucky by chance resume
to find in Spanish archive
but there's not much there in part because
of the destruction that
Manila libraries have faced
in multiple instances
in the last 130 years.
At the same time, I
think what you bring up
around India voices or more local voices
of different actors, your
right problem is the archive
and what's prevalent.
Information or letters are preserved
and even then there are
problems around that
in terms of what we're seeing as texts
and who was able to access texts
and linguistic production at the time.
And the other was really
around botany and really
who was writing botany?
And botany was in Spanish
and English primarily
if we're thinking about
institutional Lunean botany.
Had I had more time with the dissertation
and this is really the
objective for the manuscript
is to become a little bit
more methodologically creative
going about these sources.
And I got to this a little
bit with Cresa's question
how am I looking at different
source materials then
for newer archives to
bring out other individuals
who were carrying plant
knowledge at the time?
Finding voice can sometimes
be a lofty endeavor.
I think giving voice to particular actors
is one that requires a lot
of ethical responsibility
that I don't take lightly.
But when I think of for
instance, weavers at the time
who were certainly
carrying plant knowledge
I'm pushing myself to look
at these different sources
non-textual sources for trying to map out
what that plant monology may have been.
Another group of actors would
definitely be collectors
plant collectors, local guides.
These were by and large
people that were hired in situ
to assist colonial botanists and foresters
with wood collecting or with surveying.
Local guides and collectors sort of appear
in the dissertation as
you're probably familiar with
Maximo Ramos, who becomes
the main collector
for the US colonial
outfit alongside other men
who were working for
the Bureau of Science.
Again in their archives
are really disparate
I mean, they're found sort
of just mentioned in passing
on places like J store plants
through Clemons archive
through some of Meryl's archives as well.
And so even piecing
together their stories,
what their life may have been
the different kinds of
knowledge they brought
into the institutions as people
from a particular location
in the colony of people who had decades
of collecting experience.
Those are the kinds of actors
I really wanna bring out
in the manuscript.
I don't wanna lose sight of Garcia
I still think that he's
a really important figure
to bring out
and I think you also bring
up an important point.
He's also still kind of
more of an illustrator
into larger figure that
becomes important even in
sort of the story of
botany and the Philippines.
And so I definitely don't wanna lose him
but I hope that sort of
answered some of your questions
for how I might start to
think a little bit more
about mining, different
archives for botanical knowledge
where the colonial archive
is very insufficient.
Post 1945 super interesting time,
really cool stuff going on.
I've started collecting
some oral histories
with botanists who trained
or conducted research
during the cold war and what I love
and I'll just kind of
give you a snippet here.
When I'm asked, how did the cold war
impact your research by and large?
They say it didn't.
And so I thought to myself
like, okay I'm gonna begin
the next book by saying
the cold war didn't happen
for Philippine botanists
and really dive into
where these comments are
coming from because certainly
botany was exploding
in the post-war period,
it was really ramping
up even under Marcos.
And so the way that I want to
attend to this next project
is looking at how plants and
the scientists who studied them
are kind of also partaking in
sort of this political project
of new Philippine
independence in some way.
And what I also think
is really exciting is
kind of taking on the
notion of agential realism
or plant agency and all of us too.
So how do we start to think
about plants as sort of being
historical actors alongside
these plant scientists?
And I think that's a
kind of a fun exercise
to start to imagine.
And I don't mean to say that I'm arguing
about plants necessarily
have sentient decision-making
powers over the actors, you know
that I'm looking at in this time period.
But I'm wanting to really
push us to think much more
about plant growing
patterns, plants movement
across the archipelago.
As you know, people at UC Santa
Cruz are really fond to do
is just start thinking with plants
start writing with plants,
to allow for a very different
kind of history to come out,
especially in the cold war
period in the Philippines
as you know that's really been dominated
by a particular set of literature
that's focused on Marcos.
I think that's focused really well
on domestic and transnational protest
but it hasn't maybe done enough
yet to look at the science
and what science is doing.
And I know Kirby on the
call is doing that too
so I'm really excited
about the post 1945 work.
- Thanks for all these
stimulating questions
and answers we're at about
one o'clock typically
I tell everyone at this
time that I'm gonna keep
the session open for
another 15 minutes or so
but I also give permission
to those who need to leave
at one o'clock to do so gracefully.
And I just wanna thank everyone
for being with us until
now, but we will continue
we have a few more questions
after about 1:15 or so
I'll turn off the recording
and then we can have an open
chit chat session as well.
So stick around if you have the time
but you're also free to go if you need to.
So we have a question
from Tri Phuong, Tri.
- Hello, doctor professor Gutierrez.
Thank you for a wonderfully stimulating
conversation that we've been having.
My question is very brief.
I wonder if you could speak to,
or speak on or share with us
how you happened upon or
discovered intimately botany
as a heuristic and also
a modality for unpacking
and studying Filipino
history, culture and society.
That's all.
Yeah, thanks Tri good to see you (laughs).
You know, yeah, I can answer
this a few different ways
I mean, I think in terms
of my own professional
intellectual trajectory
before I entered into academia
I was in public health for many years.
And I thought that when I
entered into my doctoral program
for those of you who are maybe
still in the starting stages
of figuring out the PhD project
I thought I was gonna work
on colonial public health.
A good way to begin in that
is through medical botany
which becomes a really important facet
of Philippine public health.
I worked with Laura Nader,
who is also an anthropologist
who's worked with Erik a little bit
and he really encouraged me to look at
Philippine medicinal plants.
And that really took me
back to my dad actually
because I had known
somewhere down the line
he had written on medicinal
plants and Philippians.
And so I thought, you know what,
let me just ask my dad
about the avocado you know (laughs)
and like it's material medical quality.
And that just started some
pretty amazing conversations
and discoveries for me and
sort of the gaps in literature
about the history of
botany and the Philippians.
The lineage of botanists
is very very narrow
you can really track who learned from whom
especially over the course
of the 20th century.
And as I started to sort of
envision my dad in that lineage
and he certainly is in that lineage
I started to become interested
in sort of tracking back,
further back to find kind of
the debates within botany,
the gossip, you know in botany.
But the really amazing stories that reveal
parts of Philippine history,
otherwise maybe obscured
or not as clearly seen
through something like botany
in the past.
And so it's a very personal, I think
and also intellectual trajectory of mine.
And I'm really always, proud
of saying that that much
of my work or like love letters
to my dad for a scientist
who I think has been pretty
peripheral in many ways
even in his sort of experience
with the aspirin in the United States.
And so I think that's kind
of my short long answer
to why botany now, but I
think it's still opening up
greater investigations again,
of other plant sciences
and other ways of thinking
about the environment
that are feeling very natural
to the progression of this trajectory.
- Thanks for that.
Harry, go ahead and ask your question.
- Thank you professor Gutierrez
for being so generous and thoughtful
in your exchange with us today.
Actually my question, you
touched on it a little bit
in your thinking of over and around
lots of historical actors.
But I was wanting to ask a
little bit about perspective
'cause it strikes me that
when we look at plots,
we kind of glean alternative a
new or different perspectives
on cartography, on
questions of nationhood,
on regionality and on history.
Looking at plants teaches us
to look at Malaysia and see
the kind of relationships
that create different grounds
to like think of your history.
But also kind of, I've been
thinking about how plants
looking at plants, teaches us to look
at history from the ground up
and this kind of like working
like a methodological kind of
insistence on like a visuality
that's like from below.
But then that led me to think
a little bit about perspective
and thinking about plants,
not just as objects of study
but as subjects of studying with.
You know, plant knowledge
being not something
that botanists bear but
if they need the knowledge
that plants bear like
plant knowledge being like
plant epistemology.
So I guess my question
I'm struggling to know
exactly where to go with this
and maybe it's just a prompt
to you to speak a bit more
about plants and historical activists.
But I'm also wondering
about why they're thinking
relationing with plants
or thinking through plants
as subjects of (murmurs) can
lead to maybe kind of like
unsettling of like the visual
as this kind of like motive
of kind of like rational
domination and like transparent
understanding of history.
And what is your perspective
on the idea of the perspective
of the kind of ways that
plants can intervene
and interact and produce
history themselves.
- Yes oh, it's so cool.
Yeah no thank you, Harry.
I think that that's yeah,
I can share a little bit of some ideas
that I've been sort of teasing through
to answer this question for myself.
Think it's a very fun
one and I can just share
and just say to you that kind of idea
of ground up visual
reality and perspective
and methodologies it's so great.
I never thought of it like that,
I never thought of it like that
and I think that's important for work
for how we might start
to just, again undo maybe
a little bit more of a
human centered approach
even in a field like history, right?
Which I think some fields of history
have done a marvelous job
at sort of undoing, right?
When we're thinking about plant agency
I go about this in one particular way
would be a Imelda Marcos toad lily.
And it's again, an exercise in
just suspending for a moment
the idea that humans had control
of the entire situation
in the discovery naming
and promotion of this
Imelda Marcos toad lily
which had been discovered in
the 1970s and named after her.
In particular, I'm curious
about how this one Lily
which is actually, known
to grow around Taiwan
and Southern China
somehow manages to end up
at the Southern snip of
the Philippine archipelago.
Nowhere seen anywhere
else in the archipelago
but is somehow in this
location found among
the purported cave dwellers
that thacadye people
if you're familiar with Philippian
at the biological industry
the thasadye were purported
to be cave dwelling people
that were discovered
suddenly by the Marcos regime
this lily was discovered among them.
And it was named after Imelda
Marcos to kind of uphold
the Marcos's legacy in
supporting indigenous peoples.
We find out later in history, of course
that the thasadye were a huge hoax.
We had discovered of
course, that the Marcos's
were plundering hoaxes themselves.
But I questioned for a moment and I wonder
that this one plant that's
able to jump somehow
from Taiwan all the way to
the edge of the Philippines
in a very, very remote location,
somehow participated in the hoax as well.
I mean, it becomes subsumed
in this kind of laughing stock
that the Marcos's become after
they're pushed out of office
in 1985.
And I like to think about that.
I mean, how can we think of
a plant who is simply working
outside of its growing range
is also contributing to this?
And that's where I think plant
agency sort of intervenes
a little bit more when we
think a little bit about
how plants are sort of
actively creating communities
of people themselves, right?
Ontologically speaking,
communities of botanists
can't exist without plants, right?
How do those constitutions
then change over time?
How was a particular moment
like the cold war Philippians
being constituted in science
not only because of political
social, intellectual forces
but because of the
plants that are presented
or presenting themselves to botanists too.
And I think that's a shift
in perspective that allows
for a very different kind of
storytelling that allows again
for a little bit of a de-centered approach
to the human actor.
I hope that answers your question Harry.
- Such a fascinating conversation.
I'll turn it to Thuy
for the last question.
And then after that, we'll turn
to our informal conversation
and I'll stop the recording
after the reply to the go ahead Thuy.
- Okay thank you, professor Harms
and thank you professor I'm not sure
I can pronounce your name correctly.
Gutei?
Okay so I'm Vietnamese,
I'm not Filipinos (laughs)
and I'm not in life science
environmentalist or something
but I have long time
working in the family union.
So I work very closely with
farmers and I see your research
I guess the reason (murmurs)
I'm waiting for the book.
I have a question about like,
when I work with farmers
and interesting in development,
I care about development.
So when I work with the farmers
I talk a lot with the
farmers in the Mekong Delta.
A lot of them complain
about like the botany
like that's very interesting reason.
There is about like 19th
history, early 20th century
not at the present, not about development
but when I talk with the
farmers, they come in about
a lot of firsts kind of
disappear and a lot of grass
even grass and plants, we don't
see anymore in the fields.
And so growing up in the
village so my family,
my parents are farmers.
So my entire childhood in the gardens.
So what about like 20 years now?
I don't see a lot of plants because of
like the developments
people don't work in the
farms in agriculture.
So they don't have farmers to work
and to pick the grass like I did before.
So they use a lot of
chemicals in the Mekong Delta,
in my village in the South of Vietnam.
So to me development affect the botany
like a lot and even in my garden now
my mom had to grow grass.
(mumbles) We have a lot of grass before
and when I came here I
went through the path
I see a lot of grass that I saw before
and I don't see it now in Vietnam.
I only see it in the botanical garden
when I went to the botanicals
I saw a lot of them in
the botanical gardens
that the farmers complain to me
that they don't see it anymore.
So do you have any plan
that you do research
like the effect of development
botany in the Philippines
or in Southeast Asia?
I think Vietnam have that too.
So that's just my question
about your future plans
because I don't have knowledge
about your best (mumbles)
and I haven't read your work.
Okay, that's my question.
- Yeah thank you so much Thuy
I appreciate the question.
I'm not sure if Megan
is still on the call too
but I actually think that,
even if I were work in history
I absolutely find myself
responsible to being responsive
to contemporary conditions
that might very well impact
the environments of Southeast Asia.
I only ask if Megan's on the
call because I'm making a plan
for the center for Southeast
Asian coastal interactions
which brings together
different disciplines
including history, anthropology
and the life sciences
to attend to these bigger
questions that really confronting
Southeast Asia today.
Much of the focus right now
at the center has been on
coastal life, for instance mangroves
and mangroves degradation
but then also mangrove rejuvenation.
And ability to regenerate in spite of
the climatological
changes that are impacting
Southeast Asia in ways that
I don't even have to explain
because I think we're pretty
well aware even on this call
about what we're confronting
right now in the region.
I think in terms of the
historical lands that I know
I'm really excited to try to
offer and to continue to build
is the question of disappearance
and for whom disappearance
becomes important?
And so even when we think of
deforestation, that's happening
at the turn of the century,
the actors that are
writing perhaps the most on deforestation
are colonizing foresters
who become pretty involved
in why timber trees for
instance are disappearing
at such a fast rate?
And become much more
invested in policing forests
in order to prevent for instance,
locals from taking down trees
that aren't ready to be feld.
And so these questions of
development really tie into
well whose one disappearance
is being valued
at the expense of what kind of development
that's happening at the time.
And then of course there's
excavation, I think as Orven
and others are really
trying to really insist
on the different kinds of
perspectives in relationship
to that disappearance.
Sometimes it's harder to find an archive
but I think it's still
all the more relevant.
And you must maybe look for instance
at different kinds of sources.
I think this is where songs,
poetry, particular kinds
of folklore that we might
be able to track back
to this time period become important.
Because then we're able to see
what that discourse might be
on the fast vanishing
forests that become really
the preoccupation of colonial botany
at the turn of the century.
So I hope that answers your questions
we should definitely try to see you
at some Seacoast meetings
that are still online
and hopefully you can bring
your Vietnam perspective too.
- Well, thank you professor Gutierrez
for such a fascinating and generous
and wide ranging conversation
and for sticking with us
for so long and entertaining
all of our expansive questions
it's really been quite fascinating.
So first I wanna just
have everyone join me
in thanking you for such a fantastic talk
and give you a round of applause (claps).